welcome to that video to this video this
video right yeah you see my rating as
has plummeted quite a bit and I must say
that I was only playing badly I played a
game before that which I simply cannot
upload because I cursed so hard she was
impossible I mean there are some
probably gather kids watching that and
it's impossible for me to upload that
I'm really playing like a [ __ ] I
normally don't know what's happening
here the the game before that I mean my
opponent just gave me a piece for
nothing and I managed to lose that
miserably on time ok I'd like look at
two pieces up here and so on but it was
still long time I curse so I couldn't
upload that stuff and yeah really I
don't know what's going on I replay like
really badly ok let's see what happens
here I'm your job load thought that no
matter what I mean yeah whatever
yeah I am currently I don't have any any
game some or videos pre-produced I'm
sitting here on a on a Wednesday evening
german time and i'm producing the video
forum for thursday and yeah let's see
what i can do I already play badly it's
that it looks like I need some I don't
know it's difficult do I need a break
but I had a very long break it seems
that I'm just rusty and yeah usual usual
procedures just to continue playing and
it will get better at some point but
yeah I don't know what is this guy doing
here we are close this is not exactly
but almost a theoretical position and
luke t 1 is the most I mean it's the
kind of what else move yeah otherwise
loop the aid will come and that that
doesn't make any sense to to allow so um
an interesting moment is that my pawn
their on b7 on I can try to keep that
and play Bishop d7 next I mean I can
play AG rugby aid let's do that it's a
bit slowish but Bishop d7 maybe Bishop
c6 is coming I know that is triple
points but but anyway I have to get that
Bishop moving
yeah we shouldn't forget that black here
open up so that's not bad one bad thing
I ever bought my position is that my
queen is a bit off side so if he goes
let's say something like 94 he might
have Knight f6 at some point and just
attack my king with my queen being
offside
that's curious I mean I played
relatively quickly but he's taking ages
ok so pick up d7 this is one of those
moments if he goes Knight f6 check takes
pawn takes is threatening Queen g-form
and checkmate have they left it is so
dangerous I go pro I'm not sure if that
works really good work Bishop d7 out of
six text takes King age 8 and it's also
Queen Queen to h4 this kind of thing mmm
that's not tough to believe that it
works okay he never wanted to go there
this the serm attacks the b7 porn but I
wasn't so concerned here the ship c6
however can take and play night to a 6
which is a fork hmm no came and be
sadness hanging huh so it's a bit
difficult
yeah I cannot really give him be seven
now maybe I can but what is my move we
should somewhere look the eight is not
possible mm-hmm I don't want to give him
that pawn okay come on let's go back
it's not not as bad as it looks I don't
see a huge problem with that move
besides the fact that is can backwards
just backwards development can I go here
night a for maybe get rid of that get
rid of the night and possibly go be fine
if he moves the night back i might go be
five
57 CA that that wasn't really brilliant
but anyway so he will probably get this
pawn back now b3 I did not see
unfortunately okay if i go here Quint
eggs i can take with the Queen on on
only five yeah maybe that's not that bad
I can get it Bishop a six maybe or the a
bishop a six looks kind of good my
structures net not so bad okay Bishop a6
he might have c5 so anything better
should be seven looks looks a bit
strange so anyway to not I can do this
this is severely ricans d6 but it keeps
the pawn fixed so I can try that it's a
bit more ambitious fortunately rook the
aid is no move I cannot really get rid
of his queen it takes you for now ok
let's do it wow I'm so blind what what
is what am I doing here this is like
this is like great a great I don't know
this is childhoods texican I should see
that stuff I don't see anything here
that's that's really miserable huh
time morning black resigns nothing is
really nothing happening yet some can
just go g6 or whatever and then we
continue that game yeah that is this
move I don't really want to analyze that
it's totally useless if I blunder
blunder like kids tactics it's it's
useless those games the opponents are
just too strong for that you cannot you
cannot play nonsense like that then you
lose every game wow that's a fairly
normal theoretical position and yeah I
don't know okay that wasn't the most
brilliant idea here going here and going
forth but even that I mean the position
was kind of was kind of was kind of okay
i guess um however that is not a
possible move takes takes and this moved
wins for white that's kind of amazing
group d 8 book to a twins hmm funny so
night a4 was a big mistake 95 is still
kind of okay yeah it was a bad game I
don't know my game is totally off Bishop
d7 I was only consideration that move
which is not working it's kind of
interesting but it's not working but I
wasn't really so much looking at this
which is to stronger attacking here at
the taking the bishop term yeah I had to
do that and here well he could have one
here but Queen age for this yeah poor
Queen takes again it's much stronger
than Ruby aid yeah my back rank is
terribly weak that also wins and yeah
I'm okay again yeah and now I mean I
don't know I simply didn't see the move
I I saw my background but hey I know I
didn't see it I just didn't see it I'm
30 second
and the position is okay I don't know
yeah I just have to continue and see to
get out of that slump it's kind of weird
sometimes have those those drops back in
reading that I totally totally
inexplicable normally I maintained over
2,500 with no particular problem and now
I'm losing every game I don't know
thanks for watching guys